شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في محادثات
جمعته برئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس في رام
الله بحضور مديريه المخابرات المصريه
والاردنيه على ضروره خفض التصعيد في
المنطقه مؤكدا معارضه بلاده اي تحركات
تصاعب حاله دولتين كتوسيع المستوطنات
واعمال الهدم والمس من الوضع التاريخي
للاماكن المقدسه في القدس
[موسيقى]
مسيرات ما ابرز نتائج جوله وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في المنطقه وما الافكار التي
حملها للجانبين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيلي
لتحقيق تهدئه فوريه كواحده من اهم اهداف
زيارته المعلنه وما دلالات ومشاركه مديري
المخابرات المصريه والاردنيه في مباحثات
بلانكن مع الرئاسه الفلسطينيه هل حصل على
تعهدات اسرائيليه بوقف الحمله التي تشنها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمنيه المتطرفه ضد
الفلسطينيين منذ تواليها سده الحكم وكيف
يستجيب لمطلب السلطه في وضع اليات ملزمه
لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني ما هي فرص نجاح
الدوري الامريكي في تحقيق التهدئه وخفض
العنف وكيف سينعكس نجاحه او فشله على
استقرار المنطقه ومستقبلها
[موسيقى]
دون ان يفضح عن التفاصيل تحدث بلانكن عن
افكار واجراءات تم طرحها في اللقاء الذي
جمعه بالرئيس الفلسطيني
بامن وتفوق اسرائيل بتشير في المقابل
لانها ترفض تصعيب حال الدولتين والتوسع
الاستيطاني وقرارات الهدم والمس من الوضع
التاريخي للمقدسات في القدس متابعه اولا
ما قاله
خالص
اي اجراء من اي طرف يجعل من تحقيق حل
الدولتين اكثر صعوبه وكنا واضحين بان هذا
يشمل اجراءات من قبيل توسيع المستوطنات
واطفاء صفه الشرعيه عليها واعمال هدم
البيوت واخلائها من ساكنيها وكذلك تغيير
الوضع التاريخي القائم للاماكن المقدسه
وبالطبع نعرض ايضا الدعوات لممارسه العنف
والتغاضي عنها
حمل الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كامله المسؤوليه عن التصعيد
والتوتر الذي تشهده الاراضي الفلسطينيه
عباس قال ان سبب ما سماه التصعيد الدامي
يعود الدولي عن اعمال اسرائيل
لم يقبل شعبنا باستمرار الاحتلال للابد
ولم يتحدث بالامن الاقليمي بالسباحه المق
دسه
كرامه الشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
مناقشه موضوع مع ضيفينا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
للاسف اقرا شيئا واحدا وهو ان الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه تريد تهدئه على حساب
الشعب الفلسطيني
وكل الحديث يتمحور حول التهدئه والعوده
الى التهدئه ولكن هو يواصل الحديث عن حل
الدولتين دون ان يقول ماذا سيفعل للوصول
الى حل الدولتين الذي يعرف تماما انه قتل
بجرافات الاستيطان والاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ما رايناه نفس الموقف الامريكي المنحاز
لاسرائيل في كل الادارات السابقه والحاليه
ادانا ما حدث للاسرائيليين ولكنه لم يدن
بكلمه واحده المجزره التي ارتكبت في مخيم
جنين لم يدن عمليات القتل والاضطهاد التي
يتعرض لها الفلسطينيون لم يدن اعتداءات
المستوطنين التي وصلت الى 150 اعتداء
ليليا ويوميا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله منذ ثلاثه او اربعه ايام ولم يد
عمليات هدم البيوت التي تجري على قدم وساق
في كل انحاء فلسطين وخاصه في مدينه القدس
مما ادى الى الانتفاضه شعبيه في جبل
المكبر اذا ما سمعناه ورايناه نفس الحديث
والاستمرار التستر حول كلمه حل الدولتين
دون الاستعداد لفرد عقوبات على اسرائيل
تجبرها على وقف الاستيطان هو بمثابه
التعايش مع ما تقوم به اسرائيل او قبول
بما تقوم به اسرائيل من تدمير كامل
لامكانيه قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله هذا
هو الواقع همم السفير كراولي سمعت طبعا ما
قاله الدكتور البرغوثي وهذا يعني لسان حال
الفلسطينيين بانه ما نفع هذه الزيارات دون
ضغوط فعليه على حكومه نتنياهو لوقف كل ما
ترفضه الاداره الامريكيه توسع الاستيطان
الهدم واا ايضا تغيير الوضع القائم في
القدس والمسجد الاقصى
ورفض حاله دولتين وهو ما تقوم على اساسه
حكومه نتانيا
من الواضح اننا فقط مطلعون على الجانب
العلني من التصريحات والكلام
والتي هي جاءت بالحد الادنى في الحقيقه
وعسى ان طبعا
الاسى لما حصل
الاسرائيليين لم يفح اذى عن ذلك بصراحه عن
ايه محادثات تمت من وراء الكواليس
وهل ان اسرائيل تتحمل المسؤوليه الاساسيه
بان تعمل كل ما عليها من اجل المحافظه على
الوضع الراهن والالقاء على استثباب السلام
وعدم دفع
الامور باتجاه
الولايات المتحده قوه عظمى لكنها لا تمتلك
قوى عظمى بيدها واعتقد ان الوزير بلنكن
يفهم ان في اي لحظه زمنيه قد يكون هناك
قادح وشراره ما تشعل النيران في المنطقه
وتنجدها كما راينا في الايام القليله
الماضيه ابقى معك السفير كراولي ولكن ما
امكانيه ان تلتزم حكومه متطرفه مثل حكومه
لا تقبل بحاله دولتين تريد ضم الضفه
الغربيه توسيع المستوطنات هدم المنازل كيف
يمكن ان تلتزم بما يقول بلانكا بانها
افكار طرحت لخفض التصعيد باقضاض لو سمحت
نعم اعتقد ان هذا ربما شكل الجزء الاساسي
من حديثي الوزير الخارجيه ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
والتوقع ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي عليه
ان يقر بان هناك عناصر داخل حكومته
ستصعب الامور وان عليه ان يحافظ على
تصرفاتها هؤلاء الوضع كما هو حقيقه
انا اتفاجئت من
ماذا ترخيص الوزير بلنكن على الوضع الراهن
والحاله الفوريه الراهنه الان في الحقيقه
قال انه لم ياتي الى المنطقه حاملا خطه
امريكيه لتحسين الاوضاع فقط شجع
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين سوريه مع
البلدان المجاوره ومصر ان تعمل جميعها
سوريه
عن ذلك لاحقا الدكتور مصطفى حضور
المخابرات الاردنيه والمصريه اجتماع لكن
والرئيس عباس ما الدلالات التي يحملها
لا هم لم يحضر الاجتماع حضر يعني التقوى
قبل الاجتماع بالرئيس الفلسطيني
تقوم بضغط هائل على السلطه الفلسطينيه
بكل الوسائل الممكنه لاعاده التنسيق
الامني وهذا امر يرفضه الشعب الفلسطيني
رفضا باتا وقاطعا ليس فقط التنسيق الامني
بل كل فكره وعقيده التنسيق الامني مع قوه
الاحتلال التي تتطهد الشعب الفلسطيني
لذلك هذه الزياره كما لاحظت تركز فقط على
موضوع واحد التهدئه التهدئه التهدئه ومره
اخرى على حساب الشعب الفلسطيني دون ان
تاخذ في الاعتبار ان كل ما جرى ويجري هو
بسبب الخيار الاسرائيلي بانتخاب الحكومه
الاكثر عنصريه واجراما الحكومه الفاشيه
التي فيها فاشيين عنصريين هو لم يتطرق
لذلك بكلمه واحده
منها هؤلاء اليس بين كبير من صنف ارهابيا
في حركه كان حتى في الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل طبعا ولكن هم يغمضون العين عن كل
ذلك وعن عن عن عمليات الاستيطان المنفلته
من عقالها وعن المستوطنين الذين يقوموا
بالاعتداءات على الفلسطينيين اليوم دخل
مستوطن الى مدرسه في حواره في منطقه نابلس
وكاد ان يدهس عشرات الاطفال الفلسطينيين
اذا نحن نتحدث عن وضع خطير وهم يركزون على
الضغط على الفلسطينيين لماذا لانه في
محاوله لمنع الشعب الفلسطيني من الاستمرار
في المقاومه يعني الجانب الامريكي يريد ان
يحرم من الفلسطينيين من حقهم في المقاومه
للظلم والاحتلال ونظام الابر تايد العنصري
والاحتلال هو الاطول في التاريخ البشري
الحديث حتى لو كانت المقاومه بالذهاب الى
الامم المتحده حتى لو كانت المقاومه
بالذهاب الى محكمه العدل الدوليه التي يجب
ان ترعى تطبيق القانون الدولي اذا كان
يريد ان يحرموا الفلسطينيين من حقهم في
المقاومه باي شكل من الاشكال ويريد فقط
تهنئه مع استمرار الاستيطان ومع استمرار
القمع والقتل هذا يعني انهم منحازون
بالكامل للجانب الاسرائيلي وانا استغرب
يعني في جمله استغربتها جدا عندما يقول في
النهايه الامر ما نوط بالطرفين وعلى
الطرفين ان يحل المشكله طب ليش ما يستعمل
نفس المنطق في روسيا وفي حاله روسيا
اوكرانيا هل يقول ان على اوكرانيا وروسيا
ان تجلسان وتحل المشكله لماذا المعايير
المزدوجه لماذا عشر الاف عقوبه في حاله
روسيا في خلال شهرين ولا عقوبه واحد على
نظام الاحتلال والاكبر طيب العنصري على
مدار 75 عاما على الاقل ليقولوا لاسرائيل
اوقف الاستيطان ولكن ذلك لا يحدث ولن يحدث
وعمليا حل للدولتين قتل قتل بالمستوطنات
والجرافات الاسرائيليه
باي لحظه ان الفلسطينيين يمكن ان يعيشوا
او يقبل ان يكونوا عبيدا للنظام الابر
تايدر العنصر السفير كراولي همم
الحضور الاردني المصري همم
لقاء عباس بلانكن او او قبل اللقاء كما
قال الدكتور واوضح لنا قبل قليل همم بعد
ان التقى بلانكن القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين في تل ابيب هل هل تعتقد بانه
هذا يحمل اي ضمانات من تل ابيب للسلطه
الفلسطينيه
حيث كان هناك عمل من جانب القوات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا كان هناك اعمال من افراد
فلسطينيه واسرائيل ادت الى فقدان اناس
حياتهم للاسف هذا هو الموقف الذي نرى
انفسنا ازاءه حيث بامكان الافراد ان همم
يقوي الضوء حاله الهدوء واستسباب الامن
ان الوزير ربما حث محمود عباس والسلطه
الفلسطينيه على استئناف التعاون الامنيه
مع اسرائيل لان هذا سيحمي حياه
الفلسطينيين انا متاك متاكد من ان
المسؤولين الامنيين المصريين والاردنيين
قد فعلوا ذلك ايضا لتشجيع الطرفين على
استئنا في حاله الهدوء هذا هو هذا هو
التحدي الماثر ان انا لا اتفق معه مصطفى
بان
المسؤول فقط يتحدثون بدون ما يعني كلامهم
وبمعير مستوى عن دولتان وكل ما يحاولون هو
فرض الامر الواقع وبدون ان نعمل شيئا له
طبع المسؤوليه
تحرك راسك بالنفي عندما تحدث السفير
كراولي عن ان التنسيق الامني يحمي
الفلسطيني وعن هذا التنسيق سال بالمناسبه
هذه تايمز اسرائيل نقلت ااا ان الرئيس
محمود عباس خلال لقائه وليامبرز مدير
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه بانه قال له
بان التنسيق توقف جزئيا ولكن هو ممكن ان
يعود هل ترى في هذه الزياره ضغط على
السلطه الفلسطينيه لاعاده التنسيق الامني
المهم بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي
اصلا في كل الزياره لا ارى الا ضغطا من
اجل اعاده تنسيق الامني تحت عنوان استعاده
الهدوء ولكن كيف يمكن ان يقال ان التنسيق
الامني يحمي حياه الفلسطينيين طيب التنسيق
الامن كان قائما حتى وقوع مجزره جنين في
العام الماضي كان في تنسيقه 240 شهيد
فلسطيني سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال منهم 50
طفلا هل حماهم التنسيق الامني يا اخي
الاسرائيليون التنسيق الامني جزء من
التفاقه اسرائيل ماذا قالت اتفاق اصله في
عام 2002 عندما اجتاحت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه كل الضفه الغربيه هل التنسيق
الامني يعني انه الدبابات الاسرائيليه
والجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاتلين الاسرائيلي
يستطيع ان يدخلوا اي مدينه تحت سيطره
السلطه الفلسطينيه يفترض ويقتل فيها من
يشاؤون حيثما يشاؤون لا التنسيق الامني
ليس لحمايه الفلسطينيين التنسيق الامني
لحمايه المحتل والتنسيق الامني الذي يريده
الاسرائيليون هو ان يسمح لهم بان ي بحريه
في كل المناطق الفلسطينيه حتى التي يفترض
ان تكون تحت سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه
ويبتشون بنا كما يريدون هذا هو التنسيق
الامني الذي يريدونه ولذلك انا برايي
القرار بوقفه كان صحيحا يجب التمسك به بل
اكثر من ذلك يجب تنفيذ باقي قرارات المجلس
المركزي الفلسطيني بالتحلل من الاتفاقيات
التي مزقتها ودمرتها اسرائيل ولا تستطيع
لا الولايات المتحده ولا اي دوله في
العالم ان تضع الفلسطينيين في قفص اسمه حل
الدولتين وممنوع يعمل اي شيء والجرافات
تدمر كل ما لدى الفلسطينيين وتتحدث حكومه
بينج فيروس موتش عن تطهير عراقي تتحدث عن
تغيير المسجد الاقصى وجعله مكان للصلاه
اليهوديه تتحدث عن ضمن الضفه الغربيه
بكاملها لم اسمع انا كلام يقال عن انه
الولايات المتحده مثلا ستتخذ عقوبات او
تهدد على الاقل بعقوبات ان اقدمت اسرائيل
على ضمن الضفه الغربيه ما الذي يمكن
للجهود الامريكيه ان تغيره على العرض
الواقع وسط ملفات عديده ومتغيرات كثيره
يبقى الثابت في الموقف الامريكي وفق
تصريحات قادت البيت الابيض هو التزام
الاداره الامريكيه بامن اسرائيل وبتفوقها
النوعين نتابع جانبا اخر من تصريحات
بلانكين هذه المره في لقاء جمعوا في وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل
التي اتاحت لتبادل الاراء مع وزير الدفاع
لدينا كثير من القضايا لبحثها يعتقدوا ان
هناك مناسبه افضل من هذه لعقد مثل هذا
اللقاء
دكتور مصطفى سريعا هل نجحت اسرائيل بتحويل
بوصله زياره بلانكن الى الموضوع الملف
الاكبر والاهم بالنسبه ربما للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومواجهه كل من اسرائيل
وامريكا ما تقول بانه نفوذ ايران في
المنطقه
على الاغلب نعم واعتقد ان اصلا الزياره
كانت مخططه لهذا الهدف لكن الاحداث التي
وقعت في فلسطين والمجزره الرهيبه التي جرت
في مخيم جنين ومتابعها من احداث طبعا جعل
الجانب الامريكي يدخل في مواضيع اخرى لكن
الموضوع الرئيسي كان وما زال ايران
والدليل على ذلك العمليه الاسرائيليه
الاخيره التي يقصف مواقع في داخل ايران
لذلك الموضوع طبعا خطيره ولذلك نحن نشدد
على انهاء الحكومه العنصريه الفاشيه في
اسرائيل لا تهدد فقط الاستقرار في الاراضي
المحتله وفي فلسطين هي ستنسف الاستقرار في
كل منطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذا امر واضح
كالشمس همم
قبل تشكيل حكومه تتنياهو الاداره
الامريكيه حذرت من توزير من تسميهم
بالمتطرفين مثل سموتر
وبنكير الان وقد
حدث ما حذرت منه قالت بان هذا سيؤدي الى
سيؤدي الى التصعيد الان لم نعد نسمع اي
شيء عن هذا الموضوع ماذا لو استمرت حكومه
نتنياهو
بالتصعيد كما يطالب بطبيعه الحال الجناح
المتطرف اليميني فيها كيف سيكون موقف
الاداره الامريكيه وموقف السيد بلانكن من
تصرفاتها
المتحده
للانخراطي بشكل مباشر مع هؤلاء الطرف
الهامشيه التي تختلف معها اختلافا جذريا
حول ما ينبغي ان يتم او لا يتم في الاراضي
المحتله وانا متاك متاكد من الوزيره
قد طلب من رئيس الوزراء
كنترول يمارس السيطره على هذه العناصر
لتفاتي تلك الاستفزازات التي رايناها في
الشهر الاول من عمر هذا الاختلاف الحكومي
وعلينا ان ننتظر لنرى كيف ان رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو سيستجيب لهذه الحاله هذه علاقه
معهوده وليست سهله بالنسبه
كانت تعمل في نتيجه اخرى للانتخابات
الاسرائيلي لكن عليها الان تتعامل مع
حكومه موجوده وتفعل ما تستطيع التاثير في
هذه الحكومه لكن دعونا نظرك ان هذا
التاثير له حدوده الدكتور مصطفى انا اعلم
بان
مواقفك دائما انت متشائم من زياره همم اي
طرف امريكي لحل القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن لا
ترى بان هذا الاهتمام الان عندما الخط
الامور همم الى ذروه فيما يتعلق بالوضع
القائم في القدس تحديدا وفي الاراضي
المحتله الا ترى بان هذه فرصه ربما
لايجاد مدخل لحل ما تقوده الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكيف يمكن استغلالها
بتقديره
انا قد اكون متشائم بشان فرص ان نسمع شيء
جديد من الولايات المتحده بسبب ليس فقط
انحياز الاداره الامريكيه بالضعفها يعني
هي لم تستطع ان مجرد ان تفتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس كما وعدت ما قدرتش حتى
تخلي اسرائيل تفتح الجسر 24 ساعه كما وعدت
يعني اشياء صغيره مش قادره تعملها
وبالمناسبه لما بيحكوا عن زياده المساعدات
اللي وكاله الغوث 50 مليون طب خلي اسرائيل
تفرج عن الملياردو دولار اللي هي اموالنا
المحتجزه لكن انا همم لستم متشائما بشكل
عام بالعكس انا متفائل والسؤال الرئيسي
لماذا فجاه صار فيه اهتمام بالوضع
الفلسطيني بسبب المقاومه الفلسطينيه بسبب
الكفاح الوطني الفلسطيني بسبب اننا كشعب
فلسطين رغم الاحتلال رغم الاضطهاد ورغم
الابارتيد ورغم ضعفنا من ناحيه القوه
العسكريه في مقابل اسرائيل استطعنا ان
نعيد جذب اهتمام العالم وهذا يثبت مره
اخرى ان علينا ان نعتمد على نفسنا وان
العالم لن الينا ولن يهتم بنا الا اذا
قاومنا هذا الاحتلال وهذا الاجرام الذي
نتعرض له وهذا حق كامل لنا شكرا لكم يا
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي في رام الله والسفير
بيجي كراولي في واشنطن
لو هنا تنتهي الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]